З кийками та однією парою кайданків на двох
заступає на патрулювання нічного потяга "Київ-Покровськ"
воєнізована охорона "Укрзалізниці".
Такі ж наряди вже третій тиждень працюють на десяти маршрутах.
Щонайменше кожні дві години охоронці обходять вагони поїзда,
аби переконатися, що усі пасажири в безпеці і не порушують правил.
Прислухаємося, як ситуація, якщо нічого такого підозрілого немає, то проходимо.
Якщо чути якісь крики чи ще щось, то зупиняємося, звертаємо на це увагу.
Прислухаємося і разом з провідником цього вагону вживаємо подальших заходів.
Рішення про необхідність залучення воєнізованої охорони у пасажирські поїзди
"Укрзалізниця" ухвалила після того, як в одному з потягів безбілетний пасажир
увірвався до купе і жорстоко побив жінку.
На крики про допомогу Анастасії Лугової ніхто не прийшов -
жінці дивом вдалося врятуватися.
Ситуації, коли агресивні пасажири погрожують, провокують
чи просто не дають відпочивати попутникам трапляються не так вже й часто,
однак і вирішити їх у поїзді складніше,
розповідає провідник з майже сорокарічним досвідом Анатолій Таргонський.
Прийшов молодий чоловік, років 30,
сів у потяг тверезий. Через півгодини
він в дуже такому "хорошому" стані вже.
І він вирішив, що до Покровська він хоче "гуляти", і весь вагон має не спати.
Викликали поліцію, але, на жаль, наша поліція прийшла тільки аж в Дніпропетровську.
І так як, слава Богу, ще маю сили, я його вивів в тамбур,
бо він нікому не давав спати, і до Дніпропетровська сидів з ним в тамбурі,
він рвався сюди, і все.
А уявіть, якби це була дівчина чи жінка?
Так що в цьому сенсі не надто ми захищені.
Ініціативу "Укрзалізниці" надати охорону в потяги Анатолій Таргонський підтримує.
Однак, на його думку, засоби захисту мають бути і у самих провідників,
адже часто реагувати потрібно миттєво.
Щось таке да, типу електрошокера чи балончика з газом для тих,
хто фізично не може справитися, бажано.
Бо є такі, що я ж кажу…
Слава Богу, їх дуже мало.
Жодної зброї, електрошокера чи газових балонів немає і у воєнізованої охорони.
Два Миколи, які патрулюють потяг "Київ-Покровськ",
кажуть, їм цього і не треба.
У вирішенні конфліктів вони покладаються на своє вміння переконувати і заспокоювати.
Хоча спеціальних психологічних тренінгів по роботі з агресорами чи курсів самозахисту
охоронцям перед початком роботи у пасажирських поїздах не проводили.
До цього вони охороняли інфраструктурні об’єкти "Укрзалізниці"
чи супроводжували вантажні потяги.
Захищати ж людей їм доручили вперше.
Однак на практиці повноваження для цього у воєнізованої охорони вкрай обмежені.
У нас чітко прописані повноваження. Вони мають право попереджувати
про припинення правопорушення,
а також викликають поліцію і передають
порушників працівникам поліції.
Хоча у воєнізованої охорони вкрай мало повноважень і немає належної підготовки,
пасажири здебільшого позитивно оцінюють нововведення "Укрзалізниці".
Мовляв, це щонайменше психологічно впливає на потенційних агресорів
і водночас дає відчуття безпеки іншим пасажирам.
Вона потрібна.
Колись я їхала і такі дебошири їхали в вагоні,
що не могли їх зупинити,
ні провідник, ніхто, так що я думаю, що потрібна.
Безпека, так, потрібна.
Якщо їдуть чоловіки, якщо вони випивають, знаєте, різні ситуації бувають,
то максимально небезпечно,
а тим більше, якщо не провідник, не чоловік, а жінка, то це взагалі.
Навіть якщо хтось захоче шкоду заподіяти комусь, все одно,
я думаю, якщо він буде знати, що в потягу є такі люди,
то його можливо це зупинить.
У таких потягах точно не потрібна,
провідникам можна видати шокер, кийок і все, тобто охорона - це зайве.
До 2015 року кожен міжміський пасажирський потяг
патрулювали два представники транспортної міліції,
ще мінімум по одному чергували на зупинках.
Однак через брак коштів і низьку статистику злочинів,
що траплялися на залізниці, її розформували.
Наразі представники воєнізованої охорони супроводжують
10 з 77 міжміських пасажирських поїздів в Україні.
Це пілотний проєкт, що триватиме до грудня.
Далі в "Укрзалізниці" вирішуватимуть, чи потрібна така охорона на всіх поїздах,
якими мають бути її склад, засоби захисту та повноваження.
Ветеран воєнної розвідки, а нині інструктор з особистої безпеки та самооборони
Сергій Мошнягул радить незалежно від наявності в потязі охоронців
чи провідників робити все, щоб убезпечити себе.
Якщо я сідаю в купе і я бачу, що мені щось не подобається в моїх сусідах,
то перше, що я зроблю - роблю ефір.
Кажу: мама, дивись, я їду зараз в потязі, ось мої сусіди.
Друге, можна сказати, що зараз спілкуюся з друзями в фейсбуці,
роблю селфі, на фоні селфі - теж саме.
Лице засвічене. Все. Це дуже непоганий варіант, хоч і примітивний.
Вони можуть відмовитися від своїх планів.
Тренер радить негайно попросити провідника змінити купе,
якщо попутники розпивають алкоголь чи демонструють
надмірну самовпевненість і залицяння в розмові.
У разі потенційної небезпеки треба докласти усіх зусиль,
аби не дозволити зачинити двері купе.
Якщо ж загроза життю є невідворотною, Сергій Мошнягул радить
захистити себе принаймні підручними засобами.
Наприклад, антисептик може замінити газовий балон,
а банківською карткою, книгою чи навіть чайною ложкою
можна завдати агресору болю і спробувати втекти.
Втім, визнаєінструктор з особистої безпеки, у стресовій ситуації
активно діяти зможе не кожен.
На місці "Укрзалізниці" я би все-таки подумав,
щоб у вагонах встановлювати тривожну кнопку.
Чому? Тому що закрили купе, так, заблокували.
Людина не може вискочити, але є кнопка біля місця,
і я просто кнопку вдарив -
спрацювала тривога, то або провідник зможе підійти
або сигнал надійде до воєнізованої охорони, якщо вона там буде.
Окрім роботи воєнізованої охорони після побиття жінки в потязі
"Укрзалізниця" почала встановлюють камери спостереження у вагонах.
В майбутньому хочуть надати відеореєстратори провідникам та охоронцям.
Окрім того, аби провідники не брали людей без квитка,
під час посадки працюватимуть підставні пасажири.
А от розділяти купе чи вагони на чоловічі та жіночі поки не планують,
мовляв, для цього бракує ресурсу.